Moving from 3-space to 2-space
we're going to lose all depth information.
This is no surprise to us, we're accustomed to it.
If you take a picture of me, my 3-dimensional
head becomes 2-dimensional, but the
immersion from my 3-dimensional head
into 2-space - the flat screen that I'm projected
onto - loses all information of the back of my head
and some part of my head becomes an edge. So a
photograph is a 2-dimensional immersion of a
3-dimensional object. Well a Klein
bottle is a manifold that really is
4-dimensional. And it's a fairly accurate
representation of a Klein bottle almost everywhere-
almost everywhere. Well, not really, because first
of all it has a thickness. Glass has a thickness.
It's also not a perfect Klein bottle
because a perfect Klein bottle
not only has zero thickness but its size
is undefined until a until Mr Riemann's
metric is defined on it. To move this from four
dimensions to three it has to self-intersect.
This self-intersection is a result of it being
an immersion. There's several ways to do that, to
cause this self-intersection to happen. One -
the way I do it - is to bend the glass around,
make a ring weld here, make a ring weld there,
make a weld here so that it's possible to
pour water in or make a connection through
here and get from the outer universe to the
sort of inside.
Can you put water in a Kleinbottle? You betcha in our physical universe.
Yeah I got that, but there's other ways to do it.
So I talked to George Chittenden over at Adams
and Chittenden Glass. George says, ah let me at
it! So he said another way to do it to make this
almost reach there and this intersection
almost reach there. This is a valid immersion
of a Klein bottle. I can go here, I can push
this up - oops - and you can kind of see that
it doesn't touch. This immersion allows an ant to
walk around here everywhere but it adds two edges -
1,2 - that don't exist in the original
Klein bottle. The original Klein bottle
has no edges and one side; this has one side
but two edges. What's been lost from the true Klein
battle into here is two edges have been introduced
and it's no longer connected from insideto outside.
- (Brady: What advantage does it haveover your?)
This has the huge advantage, as George
Chittenden said, of being slightly easier to make.
But then George says, maybe I could try doing
another one where instead of having the break here
let's make the break along here. Here we
have the neck going all the way through
and a large hole around here - let's see if
I can show that hole. Okay, hope that shows,
there's a hole that George burnt into the
side of the Klein bottle and he brings this
tube right through it.
- (That's kind of what you doin the other one except that hole then shrinks)
(to touch it doesn't it?)
- Correct, exactly right Brady. In my normal Klein model I'll shrink this hole
until it touches - what a glass blower would call
a ring weld - however these are slightly different.
For example, here, this is a genuine edge. If the
glass becomes arbitrarily thin this becomes
razor sharp. Here it's not an edge, rather it's a
place where the manifold has multiple definitions
at one point. Here, on this Klein bottle, every
point is properly defined in the entire manifold.
Here that's almost true except
around the circle of singularities
each point is defined as, oh it might be
part of this or it might be part of this.
So I can spoodle this on this one, I
can also spoodle in, however this hole
is a different approach to having an immersion.
Finally George said, well you know we could do it
so that we demonstrate that the surface of the
bottle is continuous even along here. Problem that
this has is there's a hole on the inside. So he put
a window in there so it almost looks like this,
however there's a glass window that prevents
a connection between here and there. So
in a sense this manifold is continuous
across here and continuous across here
but it still has the self intersection
of a normal Klein bottle. All of these are
different immersions of the same thing; the
point is you take a picture of my face or you
take a picture from behind me or from over here
from up there, you're going to get a different view -
none of them are completely accurate. Is this a
completely accurate picture of Felix Klein? No,
I can't tell what the back of his head is like!
I can't- I don't know how many ears he has. I know
he's got one ear, I can extrapolate to say he's got
a second ear. The 3-dimensional human being
can't be seen in a 2-dimensional photograph,
the nature of an immersion. Of course with all
these different immersions of the Klein bottle
my friend Lucas Clarke came by and he
said, Cliff I've got another approach.
Lucas looked at a Coca-Cola bottle and he
said, I'm going to turn it into a Klein bottle.
And is that possible to see that this is- the very
end of the - this is where the cap goes - he's drawn
the neck of the Klein bottle through a hole -
mind you he has made a hole like this guy here -
and he's drawn the neck through and welded the lip
of the coke bottle to the base of the coke bottle.
What's astonishing about this is
not just the mathematical immersion,
but glass people will recognize that this is
a borosilicate glass, meaning that it's a very low
expansion glass. All the- all my Klein bottles
are boros and it allows you to heat one area
without heating the entire thing. Borosilicate
is relatively easy to work with, it's called
hard glass because it doesn't expand much with
temperature, it's less likely to crack. This is
coke bottle glass, it's the cheapest soda-lime
glass that the Coca-Cola company can find. Lucas
bent all of this using soda-lime glass which
is really impressive but wait, there's even more
impressiveness about it. He was able to do all of
this glasswork and preserve the paint on it. Notice,
glassblowers would- can put labels on glass
using a ground-up ceramic called a ceramic frit.
Coca-Cola doesn't use a frit they just spray
paint it on or screen it on. Lucas Clarke not
only was able to drill the hole but he was able to
preserve the label and do all of this glass work
while retaining that it's a Coca-Cola bottle.
- (That's the actual original top that he's threaded)
(through the hole?)
- Yes it is but I suspect that he weldedanother piece onto here, in other words I suspect
but I don't know, he didn't- Lucas keep secrets
from me. I suspect that he put an additional
maybe oh 30 centimeters of Coca-Cola
bottle glass to make this work
but I'm not going to ask his secrets,
there's some things I don't want to know.
And held under water long enough...
- (So you'redoing like a sort of a 360 are you to get)
(the bubble out?)
- This hole has gotto be the same as this hole! Oh my God